Yeah.
Um, you know the Quran whenever he says
whenever whenever Allah speaks about
Jesus.
Could you mind if I just
Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah.
This belief from with Mary immaculate
conception is both Sunni and Shia
believe.
Yes.
Yes. But you see we're saying that these
are all prophets. Jesus is on the for us
the same level as Moses.
Just as Moses existed and he showed
prophet signs and miracles and all that.
Where does Muhammad come in?
He's the final prophet.
You see the point?
What?
Do you see the point? But one thing that
puts them all in the same category, if
you like,
is that they all came with the same
message of believing in one God and
worshiping one God. Going back to the
commandments and so on.
It's very interesting.
Do you see?
I hear what you're saying. I never knew
that. I thought I didn't realize you
believed this.
Pardon?
I didn't realize you had I didn't
realize I thought you had a different um
Yeah. So, so, so, so you believe in
David?
King David.
Yeah, he was a prophet. Yeah.
What?
He was a prophet.
Yeah.
Yeah. All right. Solomon was a prophet.
Yeah. We know that from
Yeah. All right. So, these are all
prophets. Abraham, I don't think the
Bible says he was a prophet, but put
this to the side.
Oh my god.
The cavalry has arrived.
Cavalry.
Hello.
Nice. Some Jewish people there.
I don't need any help.
Welcome.
Yeah. Yeah. So, we believe in this.
You don't believe Abraham was a prophet?
We believe he was a prophet. No, the
Bible doesn't I can't remember where it
says that Abraham was a prophet.
We believe he is a prophet.
Yeah, we do. Yeah.
But but the point I'm making to you is
that why believe in some and not some?
Like how do you distinguish if I wanted
to say prove to me that Moses is a
prophet and Muhammad isn't?
What would be your way of doing that?
I'll I'll flip it around this.
It's more you have to prove he was
with the idea of prophet. It's not you.
He has to be proven as a prophet, not
that he's not a prophet. So you're
asking me to prove he's a prophet. I
can't. He's not. He proved
Moses.
No. To prove that Muhammad and Jesus
were
No, no. I was asking you how
what criteria do you use?
Yeah.
To say that Moses was a prophet and
Jesus and Muhammad weren't.
The Old Testament says
where does it say that Muhammad is not a
prophet?
It doesn't. That's the point. We believe
exactly the point. We believe a prophet
has to be proved, not disproved.
Yeah.
So unless you're asking me to disprove
Muhammad, I can't do that.
I want if you want us to believe in it,
you have to prove it.
All right. You see um in there's I I
can't remember if it's Deuteronomy 18.
I'm not talking about 1818, but in the
end of the verse,
oh, let me get the verse. All right, let
me get the verse. It it gives us a
criteria, and let's use this criteria.
Is this a fair enough criteria? Yeah, I
think it's chapter 18 verse 21. But let
me let me find this. Yeah.
All right. Yeah. Yeah. Okay, I got it.
Yeah.
All right.
You with me?
Yeah.
All right. It says this. Deuteronomy.
Chapter 18: 21. You may say to
yourselves, Yeah. How can we know when a
message has not been spoken by the Lord?
This is what we're looking for. Yeah.
Are you with me?
Yeah. I'm going to get out on my phone.
Yeah.
From the 21, right?
Yeah. Yeah. If what? Listen. Listen.
This this is the criteria and I think if
if we stick to this criteria,
sorry, what what um paragraph
it says uh
chapter 18 you said?
Yeah. I think verse 21 22. Yeah. If what
a prophet proclaims in the name of the
Lord does not take place or come true,
that is a message the Lord has not
spoken. Yeah. That prophet has been that
spo prophet has spoken presumptuously.
So do not be alarmed. That's what the
Bible says. Yeah. So it gives us a
criteria.
Are you with me?
Yeah. I'm just looking at context. So
yeah, look at the context. Are what are
you on?
I'm I'm going to go through the whole
chapter.
I don't want to miss anything.
What?
Yeah. Deuteronomy 18 21-22. Yeah.
Actually, give me 2 minutes.
Yeah. Yeah. Take your time. Sure. I
don't
Let me just uh as you're saying that,
let me read you Shall I read the full
context? Yeah.
So, if we look Yeah. verse 17, the Lord
said to me,
I'm just going through the whole thing.
Give me a minute.
Should I read it out loud?
Should we read it out loud?
I'm starting from the beginning of the
thing.
Uh, from Deuteronomy 1.
Sorry. Verse one. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me read it. Let me just see it.
Don't know scripture by heart.
Shall I Should I read out to those?
Let's read out from like verse 17. Oh,
sorry. Let's read out from verse 14.
Right. Because it says the prophet, this
is interesting. The nations you will
dispossess listen to those who practice
sorcery or divination. But as for you,
the Lord your God has not permitted you
to do so. The Lord your God will raise
up for you a prophet like me among you.
I'm I'm not going into this. We've done
this to death, right? This one
from your fellow Israelites. You must
listen to him. For this is what you
asked of the Lord your God at Horeb on
the day of assembly when you said, "Let
us not hear the vh voice of the Lord,
our God, nor see this great fire
anymore, or we will die." Verse 17, the
Lord said to me, "What they say is good.
I will raise for them a prophet like you
from among their fellow Israelites."
Okay, this is something which it's it's
a translation which is problematic in my
opinion because it says and you know
we've been through this.
Yeah, we've been through that. We don't
want to go into that. But the point at
the end the point at the end
says this.
You may say to yourselves and this is
the point.
How can we know when a message has not
been spoken by the Lord? If what a
prophet he's this is the answer. If what
a prophet proclaims in the name of the
Lord does not take place or come true,
that is a message the Lord has not
spoken, that prophet has spoken
presumptuously. So do not be alarmed.
Now, it seems to me the Bible is saying
that the best way to assess the
truthfulness of a prophet is through the
prophecies of that prophet. If his
prophecies are false, then that prophet
is likely to be false. But if his
prophecies are true, then his prophet,
this prophet is likely to be a true
prophet. Would you agree with this?
Yes. But there's two points. The earlier
one is said from which is still which
we're not going to argue about that.
But that that's still a big point.
So you understand we can't agree on
that.
But you want to know why we don't
believe that's a that's so that first of
all
if we use the word then it could say
Jesus might have been a prophet but it
can't be Muhammad
because he was so no problem. So to get
rid of Muhammad respectfully.
Yeah.
The word comes in. He has to be one of
us. Muhammad wasn't. So that's good.
Then go back.
No, no. I I would I would add to I would
I would just I don't want to go to 1818,
right? Because it's been done to death.
Exactly. But that's it's an important
point.
It's an important point. I just want to
focus on 18. Look at him.
Oh, sorry.
That's right. Uh 1821 and 22. 1821 is
given a criteria for prophethood. How do
you know if a prophet is a true prophet
or a false prophet? You know, through
their prophecies because no one knows
the future except for God. So if they
especially in specific things if they
come and they say things are are going
to happen and they don't happen then
it's false. So that's why I say to you
now the Quran says many
what prophecies did come true.
Yeah. So the Quran for example if you
look at chapter 30 1-6
he made a prediction or the Quran makes
a prediction Allah we believe God makes
a prediction says
the Romans have been defeated in a
nearby lowland and by after their defeat
they will become victorious
in 3 to nine years
to God belongs the affair before and
after and that day the Muslims will be
rejoicing.
And this is the this is the promise of
God. Look how emphatic it is.
And God does not break his promise. So
clearly there's evidence even extra
Quranic evidence, extra uh Islamic
evidence which indicates that this
battle took place 8 years later. And as
the Quran says, it materialized that the
Romans defeated the Persians even though
that they were on the brink of
defeat.
Defeat. That's one example in the Quran.
But other ones, for example, chapter
24:55,
you know, where Allah says in the Quran,
you know, it says in the Quran that God
has.
[Music]
Yeah. So basically the Quran says here
that God is going to promise for those
believers and the ones who do good works
that he is going to allow them to be
successors over the land and he's going
to give them power over that land. We're
talking about the Arabian Peninsula and
clearly this is military and it could go
this way and it could go that way. No
one can predict for sure this is going
to happen. If it doesn't happen then
there's a problem. The Quran is even
more specific in chapter 48 of the Quran
where it talks about how they Muslims
will enter Mecca and finally conquer it
as we know now it's been conquered
that they will be shaving their hair and
cutting it. Meaning in the in the Hajj
pilgrimage you have to cut your you have
to either cut it fully or you have to
trim it. So they will be doing something
and when you're doing Hajj you're not
fighting. So you'll be coming in it will
be a peaceful entrance if you like and
that's what happened. There was no uh
major fighting there was skirmishes but
the Muslims were allowed to do Hajj or
pilgrimage.
These are some of the uh some of the
verse in the Quran. There's others like
you know in the Quran in chapter 56
sorry uh chapter 54.
Yeah. In surah Najim
where it says about a battle battle of
Badr. Yeah. As as the revelation as
reveals
that they are going to run away. In
other words, the enemy are going to run
away. And this was the first fight
between the Muslims and the pagans at
the time happened in 313 uh sorry with
three 313 fighters and they had a
thousand more and it was unexpected that
the Muslims would be victorious.
This was the battle of
bad the first one and and this and they
ran away after that the the you know the
disbelievers. This is a tested in
history. So these are some of the
examples but more so the hadith
literature is quite clear about where
Islam is going to spread the prophetam
he narrated in the hadith that's
narrated by
that the whole earth was projected in
front of me and I saw its east parts and
its west parts
and my my uh nation will possess its
lands what has been projected of it to
me In other words, when he's talking
about the Islamic expansion, he's
talking about a westward expansion and a
eastward expansion. If you just have to
look at the map and see where Islam
spread, but more specifically Allah, the
prophet Muhammad wasallam, he said he
referred to Yemen in a possessive
pronoun.
He said God give us you know uh or
blessings in our Yemen, our Yemen and
Sham which is basically the whole region
including but look at Jerusalem right
the prophet said
count six things before the day of
judgment comes
my death and then and then the the um
the conquest of Jerusalem which happened
at the time of
now the question is when has there ever
been really a time when a prophet said
something and it didn't come true or
when the Quran says something is going
to happen in a specific time and place
and it doesn't come true there there is
no example of that whereas you can find
that in other religions you can't find
that in other religions and we can talk
about that you know like for example the
Olivet discourse in the New Testament
the Olivet discourse in the New
Testament you have
you're not going to find me arguing
about
yeah yeah yeah right so just just look
it
But the point I'm making is this is
where you will be able to falsify
like you know the Jehovah's Witnesses at
that time they had the great depression
19 1877 or something they said the world
is going to end in 1877 it didn't and
they called it the great depression. So
you can see where someone who claims to
be a prophet gets it wrong and then
their theory is falsified. But the point
I'm making to you is that going back to
Deuteronomy 18 20-21, it's clear here
that the criteria
is the prophecies. And what we're saying
is that we have this
uh the quick answer
is the word.
You're not happy.
Yeah,
that's the quick answer. You're right.
It it demands more.
Long time
it demands more. It made the mar more
research and that that will be true.
That is true because even someone who
brings one of the signs let's say
there's two sign let's say we both agree
there's two signs there's a sign that
has to be Jewish and it has to come
Jewish even if somebody comes with one
sign we still have to address yeah we're
saying that the phraseiology let's agree
that it could mean could mean from them
i.e. the ones who are Jewish and it
could mean not it's not like that but in
either situation what we're saying is
you still have to contend because the
verses in verses 20 and 21 is talking
generally about a true prophet how do
you know what we're saying is that the
criteria has been met while saying or
what I'll leave with you is a book that
my friend has written called the
forbidden prophecies it's free of charge
download it online and look at some of
the prophecies that the prophet Muhammad
has made and remember when you're making
when you're looking at those the verses
of Deuteronomy 18 22- 21 and be honest.
Ask yourself, are you going to repeat
the mistake of those Jews that
disbelieved in Moses?
And if you believe in Muhammad, you have
to believe in Jesus. Because you know
why? Muhammad,
that's what you believe.
Yeah. Because Muhammad came with the
with the
I think I think you know me by now. I'm
not fanatic. I'm openminded. Yes.
I don't come with my always willing and
I'll look I'll look what you have there.
I'm always open.
Do you want to give you my number?
What? I'll give you my number, but don't
tell anybody about it and then otherwise
I'll be in big trouble and then you can
do it in your own time. But Forbidden
Prophecy is a book that my friend Abu
Zakaria has written free of charge from
the website. You can download it and you
can also get it as well.
And so yeah,
what's your last name?
Uh hijab. H I J A B.
That's it, right?
Yeah. Let me How do I put Oh, you got
it. Yeah, you got it. All right. Nice
one. Look at it and tell me what you
think, bro. Yeah.
It's a very good conversation. Thank you
very much, man.
Yes.